Florida Governor Ron desantis's war with
Disney World has now gone up yet another
notch with DeSantis threatening to build
a state prison right next to Disney
World which is hard to even say with a
straight face that this guy is so petty
and so vindictive but he is let me
remind you the back story here Disney
faced internal pressure some time ago
to come out and criticize what is known
as the don't say gay bill in Florida
and the don't say gay bill in Florida is
this Bill signed into law which places
restrictions on what can be taught in
Florida classrooms about gender identity
and about sexual orientation as applied
to kindergarten through third grade
there was internal pressure uh at Disney
for them to come out and say we are
against this law
so Disney did that and DeSantis and
Florida Republicans flipped out they
said that Disney is going woke and they
subsequently decided to punish Disney
including by taking control of that
District which basically operated as a
private municipal government by Disney
and it contained Walt Disney World and
some other parks and this has continued
to grow and grow and grow this is not
really a battle I think DeSantis can win
because even though I hate theme parks
I'm aware that tons of people love them
and tons of people love Disney and the
movies and and Disney is generally very
well liked and so this is a risky thing
for DeSantis to do in addition now to
saying that he is going to start sending
inspectors to look at the rides at Walt
Disney World he now threw out the idea
during an event yesterday that maybe he
will build a prison next to Disney World
take that District you know one of the
things they tried to do was was put
restrictive covenants on the land that
the district owns So if you look at this
whole special district Walt Disney
Corporation obviously owns a lot of it
but the district owns other land you
know quite frankly I wasn't even
thinking about that land uh this was not
something that was really important one
way or another we just wanted them to
live on the same rules pay the debt pay
the taxes all that stuff oh but come to
think of it now people are like well
there's what should we do with this land
and so you know it's like okay kids I
mean people have said you know maybe
maybe have another maybe create a state
park maybe try to do more Amusement uh
Parks uh someone even said like maybe
you need another state prison who knows
I mean I just think that the
possibilities are are are endless and so
that is now going to be analyzed to see
what would make make the most sense okay
so he's it's we're having fun he's
joking the crowd's laughing it's all
super super interesting
this should actually be chilling this
shouldn't send a tingle down your leg
the way uh Chris Matthews once said this
should really send a chill down your
spine because what we are talking about
here is a guy who claims to have an
ideology
of not interfering with businesses being
against regulation
uh welcoming the tax revenue that comes
from businesses I mean what we're
talking about like the state's largest
tourist attraction by far and
antagonizing them is certainly an
interesting economic and political
decision but this is yet another example
it's another data point of how they
immediately and with total Reckless
abandon will get away from their stated
principles if it's not convenient or if
they're upset or if they want revenge or
if they want to ruin somebody's day
because they don't like politically the
things that are going on he is openly
using his political power
he has already done it and he is
threatening to do more of it against his
perceived enemies including corporate
enemies this is extraordinarily
dangerous stuff and despite all the
claims that it's the Democrats that want
to over regulate and hurt business and
all these different things
I've never seen anything like this
openly and overtly and brazenly so is he
literally going to propose building a
state prison right next to Walt Disney
World I don't know maybe maybe not it's
not totally clear but this is exactly
the stuff that we've been talking about
when we say these are not only
Hypocrites but they are dangerously
dangerously hypocritical and remember
it's all over don't say gay that's how
this all started Disney said hey we
don't like this everybody's welcome here
by the way Walt Disney World I've never
again I've been to Disney once when I
was like 18. I guess they're known for
all sorts of corporate events where you
can I don't know if the park is closed
down or what but they do everything from
corporate events to Pride day to gay
weekend or whatever else the case may be
it's also profitable for Disney whatever
you assess to be Disney's political view
like does Disney have a political view
is Disney Pro gay I don't know but they
certainly know
that their bread is buttered by all
sorts of different people including LGBT
groups and tourists and travelers and
whatever else the case may be so this is
as much out of self-preservation as it
is about whatever Disney thinks is right
and fair and good I don't know that the
scientists can actually win this one but
it's certainly clear he's willing to try
just about anything in order to take a
shot at that